what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have just
one episode left of the falcon and the
winter soldier the falcon and the winter
soldier has been
great so far so hopefully we can expect
a pretty good finale to finish it off
and also hopefully a long one as the
last episode was 61 minutes hopefully
this one will come in around
an hour and a half and based off of
everything that we know about the finale
for the falcon and the winter soldier
they're going to need that time because
a lot is going to be happening based off
of everything that we know and
everything that we saw from the trailers
tv spots promotions on instagram and
twitter and
leak set photos and videos we actually
have a pretty good idea of a few scenes
that are going to be happening in the
finale
of the falcon and the winter soldier
including one in the ending
now things that we've seen aren't too
revealing after all like i said they
pretty much showed them online
somewhere but i am going to be talking
about what i think is going to happen
and in case i happen to be right this is
your spoiler warning we are going to go
over
all of the scenes and talk about what
they mean so if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel content and also
i'm still giving away a captain america
shield just look out for the info in the
description and the ping comment down
below
big shout out to the twitter user at
chris deviant for putting together all
of the photos from the trailers and tv
spots that we have not seen yet
and we'll start with the first scene
which is going to be the flag smashers
attacking a police convoy
now the last time we left off with the
flax smashers in episode 5
they've infiltrated the grc the grc was
voting on whether or not to send the
refugees back that had fled to their
countries
although as we saw there really wasn't
much of a vote going on
they kind of already decided that
they're going to send the back in fact
they said that they have people in place
ready to take them back which is
obviously a big problem for
the flax masters because they believe in
no borders no
flags the whole world should be one so
they infiltrate the grc
and then the police come well it looks
like carly has a plan to deal with the
police
as we can see here she has poured
gasoline under one of the police trucks
she lights it on fire and it explodes
and the expression on her face
is pretty happy now if you notice in
this shot of the explosion we can see a
motorcycle on the ground
and we know that bucky is actually going
to ride this motorcycle
into a barrier jump off of it and attack
carly the motorcycle assumingly flips
into the air and goes forward
a little bit then lands on the ground i
believe that is what we are seeing here
now we have a few shots of bucky and
some of the other flag smashers fighting
presumably in this scene
and it looks like carly clearly blows up
this police vehicle
after this fight which makes us question
what happens to bucky did the fight take
them to another place and bucky is off
fighting other flag smashers or maybe
they somehow beat him
after all he doesn't have sam with him
and bucky was barely able to beat john
walker with the help of sam so bucky
versus
one or two or three flag smashers might
actually be pretty hard for him and we
know that sam is eventually going to
show up and it's actually kind of funny
how we have
no footage of sam showing up for the
final battle that is because he is going
to be in his new captain america
uniform at the end of episode 5 sam
opened the briefcase that bucky gave him
that is from
wakanda that is going to be his new
captain america uniform presumably
with wakandan technology vibranium wings
and vibranium
lacing in the uniform and luckily we
only have one more day to wait until we
see that uniform
now in this next scene we can see all of
the chaos that the flag smashers are
causing in new york city and at the grc
we see more explosions of police
vehicles that are surrounding the grc
we see helicopters flying around it and
we see people evacuating the building
and in the background we can see that
everything is red just like at the
ending of episode 5.
so we know that the flax masters have
infiltrated the grc
some of them are already inside which
leads me to believe that they are
probably keeping
everybody that was in that room who was
voting hostage
anyone else in the building they are
probably letting escape their grudge is
really with this council
they're trying to take refugees who now
have a home in different countries and
send them back to where they came from
with no resources and no help and no
homes really so the goal of the flag
smashers is to try and stop this
however interestingly enough it looks
like carly is not inside of the building
but she's
outside we have more photos of a battle
between her
and bucky and it looks like she actually
kicks up a parking meter and is using
that to fight bucky but luckily bucky
has a vibranium arm
if he didn't it looks like it would be a
relatively hard battle for him
but luckily he has the arm and as we can
see here in these photos it looks like
he's got the advantage over carly as we
see him throw her
most likely into something now we know
this isn't going to be the end of the
fight for one reason or another this
fight gets interrupted the reason we
know this is because we see bucky in
another scene
outside of the grc looking like he's
about to go in we see him look at the
main entrance as everybody is evacuating
and then he looks back
most likely looking at sam and again we
haven't seen sam because he's most
likely in his new captain america
uniform
and speaking of captain america john
walker
is not done yet he has been stripped of
his title as captain america but in the
post credit scene of episode 5 we saw
him making his own shield
and in a trailer we got we see him
walking down the street
with that shield in hand going up to the
flag smashers
now in this shot right here where we get
a close-up of the shield
you can tell that there's some
differences here and although it looks
pretty decent you can tell that he made
it himself
so he walks up to the flax smashers sees
carly
chucks his shield at her but as we can
see here she simply
kicks it away i've explained a few times
how the probability of it being a simple
metal and not vibranium is really
really high it's most likely just made
out of a common metal and since carly
and actually all of the other flax
smashers actually have the same type of
super soldier serum that john
walker has a perfected super soldier
serum
i'm guessing that this probably doesn't
end well for john walker
i don't think he's going to die but i do
think he's not going to be able to take
on the flag smashers alone so he's
either going to work
with falcon and bucky at the end or he's
going to get beat up pretty badly
now one final scene that we haven't seen
yet is a falcon talking to somebody
about fighting for the shield some
people think that this could be steve
rogers and although that is a
possibility if we take a look at where
he's at
we realize that this is the backyard of
isaiah bradley's home
in episode 5 we actually see this exact
staircase that is behind sam
and although it's dark we can definitely
see here in the scene with isaiah
that the stairs behind him are
definitely the same stairs that are
behind sam the only difference is
is this scene is clearly in daylight
which means sam goes back and he talks
to isaiah
maybe he could even convince him to join
the fight at the end maybe he won't join
it originally but maybe
sam's words could resonate with him and
he joins the fight by the end
now we have two pictures of sharon
carter that we have not seen yet plus we
have the scene where she's in the garage
now i said it before and i'll say it
again i will not be surprised
if she is the power broker i know
there's been a little bit of
misdirection leading us to believe that
she isn't the power broker but i still
believe she has some connections with
the power booker or she
herself is indeed the big mysterious
power broker and then we have some
photos of the end here
we can clearly see that sam and bucky
are back at sam's place
at the dock where they keep their boat
which they decided not to sell
and judging by the looks on their faces
everybody is pretty happy the
neighborhood has come together
little kids are hanging off of bucky's
vibranium arm i'm going to assume that
the community came together and they
helped sarah and sam
and of course in this episode i would
assume that bucky is going to make
amends with
yori he's going to tell him that he is
the one that killed his son
if this is not addressed at the ending i
think a lot of people are going to be
pretty upset
but i'm pretty sure that that's going to
happen and that's what we can expect
from the ending and finale of the falcon
and the winter soldier lots of action
and lots of happiness at the end and
hopefully there is some sort of a post
credit scene with the thunderbolts being
assembled
zemo got taken to the raft a place that
thunderbolt
ross actually controls and i'm pretty
sure there are some other villains in
that prison from there hopefully we see
some sort of a post-credit scene of
thunderbolt ross talking to the
prisoners
telling them that they can earn their
freedom by working for him
i don't want to hype it up too much
because i have no idea what's actually
going to happen but i would absolutely
love to see this
and i'm sure many others would as well
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the falcon and the
winter soldier videos and other marvel
videos as well
and be sure to join the live watch party
for the falcon and the winter soldier
finale will be starting at about 11
30 p.m pacific time be sure to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me